hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast panel discussion VA
genomics the clinic and research
presented by dr. Lawrence Meyer chief
officer and specialty care services
better in Health Administration and dr.
Ronald Prezi Gonski director of genomic
medicine and implementation Department
of Veteran Affairs I'm Kaylee Baca
blabbers and I will be your moderator
for today's event before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that best
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen type your
questions into the drop-down box and hit
Send well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window
involve the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Lawrence Meyer and dr. Ronald Prescott
see I will now turn the presentation
over to them hi my name is progress
kotsky
I am in the research development that BA
and my co-presenter is Lawrence Meyer
who is in the clinical side of the VHA
healthcare system we'd like to present
the general view of where genomic
medicine is and hopefully moving into in
the future within VA healthcare system
itself I'll present a couple of pieces
from the research elements and Larry
will certainly present a clinical piece
in a few seconds here I think what's
important to bring up is that VA
research development has been around for
several decades and has produced a lot
of great works that not only helped the
the veteran but general population writ
large um some examples
hurdled back s many decades out looking
at just Adam Ison and tuberculosis
treatments the nicotine patch pacemaker
treatment for hypertension the like and
several others that are ongoing at this
point as well but I what's what's
important to stress is that we have I
think an ideal setting for let us kill
population research because we we are
embedded within the healthcare system
itself and we have the access to medical
record data that it goes back as far as
twenty years as well as other records
information that could be linked with a
given individual I think what's
important also the stress is that after
the Second World War
Omar Bradley came up with the idea that
we need to have affiliate as well as
research put into the healthcare of the
Veterans Administration as it was called
back then and because of that we have a
lot of clinician researchers that are
benefitting and helping in tandem with
the given patients that they're helping
with many of the individuals as one
could imagine our clinicians over 70%
actually for be a research development
in as in much of the academic affiliates
aspect of this is a really strong and
brings the best of all health care
because we've got the advancements that
are done or used within the general
population but it also brings into and
looks at the unique issues that are at
delft which for the veteran population I
think you know what I want to bring up
is the what we're looking at the day
genomics program itself and we have a
lot of different pieces that we needed
to look at we we we wanted to develop
something you know as one angle
development provide databases of medical
and you know Madonna that we can
understand better you know uses of the
of the records as well as help with the
establishment understanding of diseases
themselves but you know one of our
issues is that we have we do clinical
trials and we do want to have the access
to the patient him or herself as well
and the recruitment and collection of
individual this amount of samples is
time-consuming costly
and difficult and we want to have that
clarity with you know the partnership of
the veteran and the researcher to get
the best health care so they can give
him we have the ability to do good
research works as well from the genomic
perspective we want to also have the
twist of understanding that you know
making phenotypic data in an analytical
standardized manner these are expensive
approaches certainly they're dropping a
price at this point but it's it's when
we were looking at this initially when I
came on probably around 10 years ago
tests were expensive much more expensive
than the than they are now and we wanted
to have a way of getting this data done
that one could one in you know one
researcher said could look and identify
information and others could repurpose
that data at some time in the future
understanding where it came from how
that what the standards were and all
that and we also wanted to have the
human subjects and data protection that
the veterans do desire that is the
protection of their data so it does not
get lost out into ether and somebody
could use that nefariously against them
or to identify individuals in particular
manners you know for whatever they you
know situations maybe but we also want
to have the ability to regardless of
that keep the data in such a way that we
could then still look at what happens
with these people throughout time so
person could come into a study today and
five years later we can find out what
has actually happened in transpired
these are V the genomic information that
we have and this is all aimed at trying
to figure out what's the best way of
finding results that could be
implemented as tests they have some
clinical utility and some clinical
validity as well ultimately helping the
veteran population
studied am predominately talking about
is this million veteran program which
we're looking at bringing on 1 million
veterans into this program it started
off in 2011 and currently we have around
six hundred seventy thousand individuals
enrolled into this program and the items
that allah stated earlier are taken into
account way we take the information put
samples and biorepository have the
information of the given individual and
their health and lifestyle and access
their medical record and the like it's
it's an ongoing program here one is
interested this is the journal and
publication that you want what the
article that you want to take a look at
and we have roughly at any given time
around 50 sites that are actively
recruiting individuals into the program
and some of these areas own you might be
actually living next door and oh the
interesting to for you to get an
understanding of what the program
actually looks like and if possible
participate if you're a veteran in using
DHA for your health care service if not
to and they spread the information to
other veterans so they can partake in
this this work just as a general
information in a panel certainly we got
predominantly males but the nine percent
females that we have there are actually
more females coming into MVP than arvind
in DHA itself itself but nominally these
individuals are of the Korean War
Vietnam era and most of the individuals
are Caucasian but there is a relatively
large percentage of african-americans
Hispanic and Native Americans as well in
the conflict in service areas of
conflict certainly scan through
different timeframes from the Vietnam
era here is that we're looking at are as
noted on this slide and they've
typically aligned with what VA is trying
to help when the veteran population we
do have a lot of presentations within
different places
Society will be Society of Human
Genetics I had allowed us to present
several abstracts and presentations
there as well and we also have an active
component of not just looking at the
genomic perspective but also looking at
how do we align these these pieces with
that other more an actually probably
more difficult area of trying to
understand which is the phenotyping how
do you actually look at the medical
record data and be able to pull out
unique values that might be then aligned
with the genomic data to help answer
some of these questions I'm just like to
illustrate one piece that Larry and I
are actually spearheading and with an
individual planning work day boazlin in
Philadelphia prime care where we're
looking at the implementation of looking
firmer could you know make data and
major depression and see if one has this
information from the firm could you know
me perspective how does the clinician
how's the patient take that into account
is there actually validity in utility of
these markers per se to help and do and
identify which antidepressants one could
or should or avoid in a given therapy of
that unique individual that is their
target numbers for 2000 individuals
around 20 academic sites and looking at
this as well and it's it's it's
developing interesting information which
I'm sure Dave Azam will bring up at some
point in the future I guess with that I
would like to ask Larry to continue with
the presentation well so thanks Ron
this is Larry Meyer Lawrence Meyer and
I've been in the VA as well as it an
academic affiliate so I'm one of those
people that run mentioned who's both at
one of our academic institutions as well
as been affiliated with the VA and I I
practiced clinical genetics and I was
asked to start a clinical genetics
program inside the VA about eight years
ago and it's been building for the last
five years and while genetic care was
available within the VA there was really
no organized nationwide structure and so
I've really been charged with trying to
roll out the clinical operation of
genetics and take all of the research
that has been developed in the VA and of
course on unabated by the knowledge base
of the human genome project and the
sequencing of the human genome and all
of the other knowledge that has accrued
over the last couple of decades and I've
got to say that just in the last six
years that we've been very actively
building this program the siting on the
standards there's really a moving target
the the knowledge that contributes to
the practice of human genetics is
expanding and continues to expand so I
just have a few slides describing the
program that's been that's been
developed in the VA and and and then I
want to talk a little bit about that the
ways the kinds of service that we give
and the ways that we give it so so first
we are a service that gives most of the
most of the encounter by televideo link
and so the preponderance of these are
done from our hub site which is based in
Salt Lake City to a Medical Center or
even more commonly one of the
community-based outpatient clinics and I
don't know the background that all of
you have about the VA but we have over a
hundred and seventy VA medical centers
or hospitals across the system and these
then have affiliated community-based
outpatient clinics or see boxin we've
got over 1100 of those so that's a
system of almost thirteen hundred of
points of care that that are nationwide
so the this slogan that I adopted was
that I
a veteran in rural Oklahoma or Montana
or North Dakota not to pick on any of
those fine states but I want them to get
the same standard of care that they
could get they happen to be born in in
Palo Alto or Boston or one of the the
hubs of genomic information and the
backbone of the VA televideo link in the
VA z' emphasis on telemedicine has
really enabled this pump to be possible
so over half of our encounters and then
of course we also use the telephone you
know that's that's a gimmick and the the
second thing is that referrals come from
everywhere about a third of them come
from our primary care clinics a little
over a quarter of them come from the
women's health clinics and that's due to
the high rate of referral for breast
ovarian cancer risk assessment about ten
percent come from hematology oncology
and that's because of all of the other
familial cancer syndromes however the
rest come from every specialty in the
entire VA and that even includes the
emergency department where we've seen
you know referrals because of conditions
such as an abdominal aortic aneurysm
which we know can be familial and so
alert clinicians there in taking a
family history call to consult
immediately and we were able to act on
that over the last five or six years our
volume has steadily gone up we're right
now at over eighty bas and trying trying
to get the ability to reach the rest
Iran showed the map of the sites where
the MVP was recruiting and I've got to
say we've with knowledge of that we've
actually tried to integrate with that
program by making sure we provide
clinical services where there might be a
research enrollment push because the
presence of that research team asking
veterans to participate often makes them
think about a family history and when
they when they bring that up to their
provider and say you know I've had a
whole lot of this particular kind of
cancer in my family they'll then make a
referral to us and and III hope that can
improve that our in care I'll mention a
little bit about the different the
different kinds of care we give in a
minute but I think an important
component of genetic care that doesn't
come first to everybody's minds is the
great mass of information and I'm sorry
this slide at least on my screen right
now it looks a little jumbled has been
moved back and forth between different
operating systems but once the genetic
test is run there's a common perception
that it's the gold standard at genetic
test will tell me everything I need to
know and be definitive and in fact the
the mass of information out of a modern
a sequence based genetic test is huge
and often very difficult to interpret
and while we we clearly know some
identified and identifiable and and
characterized mutations and we can take
those and diagnose the presence of a
trait or a risk factor and a correlate
that with a clinical response and we can
then follow that up with a different
clinical care for example recommending
more frequent colonoscopies or more
frequent breast exams or a specific
therapy it's often difficult to
interpret the tests and we see something
that we've never seen before or only
seen a few times so it's necessary to
have this information transmitted
between our health systems and be
available in the medical
at the point-of-care to the clinician
for example if right now all genetic
systems handle genetic data poorly so
across the all of the best academic
institutions in the country who is a
survey a couple of years ago and they
found that most of their genetic test
results were either as a described as a
text blob or a PDF rather than
integrated so the VA has been a leader
in an institute of medicine now the
National Academy of Medicine effort that
was termed digitized and now has termed
genomics on fire spelled F ihr for the
electronic standard that's used to
transmit this data so that we can get it
get it inserted in a structured fashion
in the medical record and then used for
computerized decision support to remind
it clinician that a test such as a
colonoscopy is due or to recommend for
or against a certain drug for example
and I think that's going to be necessary
as we integrate these clinical results
into into our practice if I can go back
to one of Ron's slides yeah just to
emphasize the the scope of the VA the
corporate data warehouse rolls up all of
the clinical data from all of these
1,300 points of care and has really been
doing that for a little over 20 years
that we've been having electronic
medical records so in total there's
about 22 million records and having
looked at pretty closely about 14
million of those have some rich clinical
data in them so not all of them some of
them are primarily administrative
records about 10 million or sell eight
or ten million but in among those you
can look at the number of clinic know
of lab orders of radiology results those
are in the billions and that towards the
scope of any other clinical system in
the world I guarantee you and so the
combination of an integrated research
effort to identify diseases and traits
and treatments which are potential
benefit to veterans and then as I work
closely with our D to roll those into
the clinical practice and spread that
rapidly across the nation I think is
unique in our healthcare systems and in
any healthcare system so we could flash
ahead here I don't mean to make you uh
busy with the slides so the places we
provide care are all the way across we
of course hope to reach all 1,300 points
of care and and increasingly we are
starting to do a direct video to home
and that can be delivered on a computer
a laptop a I've had a kind of
arrangement or on a smartphone through a
procedure called
a video connect and the VA just obtained
the authority to provide this care a to
a veteran's home across state lines
because our veterans need that
integration of nationwide care and then
finally as I promised a word of the kind
of care we provide
ten years ago when I when I started it
was largely confined to individual
expensive gene casts to address the the
risk for a very specific disease and a
lot of these tests were incomplete and
that we knew one gene was involved but
we didn't know the others since since
I've been involved with a VA clinical
effort which is a little less than 10
years we've gone from just
over a thousand diseases Matt our genes
mapped and associated and characterized
is associated with the disease to over
6000 and the technology that's used in
the clinical diagnosis of disease has
has really matured gotten much cheaper
and we now use something called
massively parallel sequencing or next
next-generation sequencing as a clinical
test sometimes if appropriate with the
confirmation and so we're using panel
diagnosis and screening for disease risk
a much more efficiency lean and more
comprehensively and we can to apply
those to the diseases where we know we
can affect clinical outcomes by their by
the knowledge that a person has a
specific kind of genetic risk and that's
still the bulk of our practice depending
on the disease and the risk factor and
the assessment of the professional
groups we have we have different we try
to hold ourselves to exactly the same
standard of care as would be practiced
to any one of the major academic or
cancer centers in in the United States
and then we're obviously closely
integrated with the practice of the of
the services such as gastroenterology
oncology mental health as is Ron already
mentioned and and making sure that the
the the clinical side feeds back so that
we help research establish the
priorities for their research direction
and and then we also gobble up the
results of research and try to make sure
that we have the best the best
information by which to guide our
clinical decisions and the though the
way we practice within the VA so with
that I think I'll we can turn it over
to the the panel discussion de meyer and
dr. Prasad ski for that informative
presentation you will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
that appear into the box and that
appears on your screen and click the
send button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question asks how do I
get into the VA healthcare system are
there downside or advantages in doing so
that's more in the clinical realm should
I take that one Ron sure I so there's
there's a process for getting in and
there are eligibility requirements now
it that has changed and it will continue
to change
I know Congress is considering
legislation so you have to be eligible
and the way to go is to to apply through
the Veterans Benefits Administration at
a regional office or that's available at
va.gov online and it's now fully online
I don't think we're at least if if there
is a downside I'm not aware that of what
that downside is many people that are
eligible for VA care choose not to get
it because they have for example their
own employees employers covered plan and
they prefer to stay with those providers
there are a large number of eligible
veterans to get one segment of their
care from the VA and other segments in
the community and and we call those that
the dependency on the VA in some cases
we treat the veteran for a condition for
which their service connected in other
cases they'll get much more of their
health care here and I think a lot of
that choice can be regional if a veteran
lives close to a VA that
call center or CBO see they're much more
likely to come to the VA but I think the
the VA care by a wide variety of studies
that the the Veterans Health
Administration care is on a par with
that in the or better than the rest of
the nation on most quality indicators so
even if somebody who's registered they
don't need to get their care here but if
for any reason they lose their
eligibility or other care or they want
to change doctors or get a second
opinion we're available great thank you
another question we have is can I
solicit for a grant if I'm not in VA
especially with MVP I think I'll take
that really the the the point with VA
research is that it is an intramural
program being that one has there are
some rules for investigators that need
to have done to be able to do any ba
research itself that one of them is
there's something called 5/8 time that
you're at least on the VA payroll that
is 5/8 of your week of hours you are in
a VA employee and then well that
individual could as a physician or as a
clinician apply for an intramural grant
some of the programs we have four major
programs within research development
that being by a medical clinical
rehabilitation and health services at
least for biomedical as I see at this
point we still have the the need for
corn court eligibility one if one is a
ph.d doctorate strictly beech need a
doctorate one needs to go through
eligibility to be able to apply for such
young there at grants certainly there
are a number of other ways that one
could also work as an outside individual
and that is pairing with
VA researcher as Ana no co-investigator
and being able to go ahead and or take
with the VA investigator in the works
that are in VA itself as well as it with
an MVP
I'll also reflux to to Larry because
Larry has been until actually not that
reasonably the associate chief of staff
for research within Utah with in Salt
Lake City and he has some ideas up
asleep as well I'm sure he'd be happy to
share yeah so I that's a question that I
often got from my affiliates family so
if you are at one of the roughly 120
academic centers that has a VA affiliate
there's a fairly easy pathway to get
inside the VA and well it's true you
need to be five-eighths to receive VA
funding to do research on an on on the
VA you need not be five-eighths at the
time of an application so you can if
you're and clinician is also apply and
then negotiate that time and effort if
it's likely you're going to be funded
the the there are differences between
the different things and then also to be
a member of a research team you need not
be at one of the major academic
affiliates so I had under my coattails
as it were people from over six
different states and all different
academic kinds of institutions and some
private research facilities that would
partner with the VA people and be able
to carry on joint research projects and
I think they had to of course follow the
standards of the VA for all data access
privacy and security and and our
standards of conduct but I think the VA
you know the recognition that we have
basically 22 billion miles in our
electronic medical records and a genetic
the largest bio bank in the world and
have a diverse clinical population is is
the luring as a place to do research and
I think the MVP the million veteran
program that Ron talked a lot about is
going to prove to me one of the best
genetic resources in the world we're
doing several different kinds of
research and we're actually interested
in having a large number of people
participate in that we don't have all
the best ideas in the world and we know
that we've got good ideas but but but in
order to receive funding you do have to
be within the VA and then there's the
screen that the project has to benefit
veteran's health that has to be aimed at
a priority of the VA that can be
identified broadly but we certainly have
the areas about which were most
concerned a TBI PTSD and mental health
suicide chronic diseases such as
diabetes renal failure of congestive
heart failure and that's a sort list but
we're we're you know you it needs to be
relevant to the veteran population
I think what's if I may interject what's
what's really interesting to note is we
like all federal agencies have several
surveys throughout the year about
satisfaction and work environment
questions along those lines and
resoundingly over 90 percent of the
people when they are polled why are you
within the VA why do you want to work
here and that the answer typically comes
up as being to service the veteran I
challenge any other organization out
there
to go ahead and have such a high
percentage focused on what you really
aren't there for I'll add one other
aspect of the VA that I don't think most
people outside our system are is aware
of as many of us inside and actually we
take it for granted I've mentioned that
there are a hundred and twenty academic
affiliates on the VA trains in round
numbers 70% of all helps providers in
the United States at some point in their
career and that doesn't just mean
doctors that means physical therapists
nurses social workers
[Music]
audiologists it's a huge number of
training programs in all of the Health
Professions and so the three missions of
va kaeh or three of the prime missions
are care of veterans but education and
research and that also contributes to
the employee satisfaction almost all of
the internal medicine providers and my
old home institution in the field were
were a faculty at a major academic
University and had time spent on both
sides of the street and were are the
quality of care was really the same and
the academic hospital in the VA and
that's that's another important mission
thank you next question asks what is the
current role of clinical tests for
disease susceptibility such as cancer
risk
so I touched on that a little bit I
think for some disease is we have very
clearly defined standards and so for the
risk of breast cancer and ovarian cancer
we use different kinds of scoring
systems based on the age of onset in the
family history including the age of
onset on on relatives to decide
it's appropriate to do a genetic test in
in other cases such as colon cancer of
we're in round numbers three percent of
the of the people with a colon cancer of
any age a genetic syndrome or family of
syndromes called Lynch syndrome or have
hereditary nonpolyposis colon cancer and
that's a that's contributed to by at
least four major genes and is a
chromosomal instability syndrome and
importantly that change buzz changes
care it results in screen and the family
members I it involves screen and organs
other than just the colon and now we
have interventions which can be
specifically used for those cancers so
identification of this is important so
one of the standards that we use is will
it result in a change of medical care
and I broaden that because I think it's
important for a person to know if they
can transmitted C's to their family
that's often an important of
psychosocial reason to have a test we
also use it as it used to be once you
thought there was a good chance of a
condition such as an adult onset
neurological disease we can perform
iterative MRIs and try to diagnose
something forever but if we think we
have a diagnosis and can diagnose it
then we can predict something about the
course of the disease even if we can't
treat it other conditions where we
commonly would apply tests are for some
of the cardiac conduction defects in the
cardiomyopathies again they involve
standards for different care so those
are
the kind of guidance we use in
determining the appropriateness of a
genetic test I can say that in very
round numbers we perform a lab based
genetic test in about half the numbers
now in my view as a clinician the most
important genetic test is a family
history personal and family history run
on the other hand is a pathology so he
may differ from me a little bit but it's
kind of hard to get an answer from my
tissue biopsy by at least an answer of
what is your family history like I went
but I can contribute is that we you can
also look at the research perspective
and how va dovetails the the research
and the clinical you know pieces
together we looked at how do we actually
approach Lin syndrome is it actually
ready for primetime can we move this out
into the clinic we had a couple of
couple of those smaller studies just to
get some baseline information we also
dovetailed with health services research
you know the group that actually looks
at how do you push this information out
and use this in some kind of a valid way
within the clinic itself and you know
certainly there's a there's some
subsections where then health services
there's the quality and asked research
initiative that you know dr. Amy Kilburn
moves and tries to get that bridge built
between research and the clinic as well
and Lin syndrome was one of those pieces
that we decided that this is ready for
primetime we had the background
information and Larry is the right
person to put this all together and move
this into the system and here's the key
thing I think that VA can it does do
very well yeah I think some other
healthcare systems might have a bit more
difficulty and that is a few people can
come up with an idea can't move this and
change the way the system is working
throughout the entirety of BHA or
veteran's health care administration
that is key that hardly ever happens in
where else without inviting in
chou-heung difficulties and
conversations and thinking here we think
we make a decision we move ahead and
yeah that's that's something that I'm
personally really happy that we are
capable of actually helping the veteran
in such a relatively quick way
would you agree Larry definitely okay we
have time for just one more question
today in this last one asks what about
use of tests that test for which drug to
use from echo genomics so Ron Ron
mentioned the the prime study so I'll
start there's a tremendous push of
pharmacogenomic testing companies now
which are trying to you know
appropriately sell their product but
saying that they can identify the best
drug to use and there there's some
clinical data I can say that the the VA
looked at this something called an
evidence synthesis panel which tried to
do an analysis of published trials and
determine that there really wasn't
sufficient evidence but let me back up a
couple of steps and say that that is the
goal of precision medicine and I think
most of us who are in this field say we
are we are hoping that we can in the
very near term develop data that these
will have improved outcomes now there
are places where pharmacogenomics is
very clearly currently up to speed and
where we're trying to roll it out as
fast as we can in our system and in many
other systems and an easy I'll give you
several easy examples one is something
called the back of ear hypersensitivity
this is a drug used for HIV therapy and
if you have a certain tissue type and a
human leukocyte antigen HLA type it
indicates that you're very high
for having a serious life-threatening a
response if you take the medication so
even though that's quite rare we think
that should be used across the board
another place where this is highly
indicated is in some of the cancer
therapy this is getting a little bit
wonky
of a but geneticists talk about two
different kinds of genetic casts Leonard
our tests of tissues such as cancer
tissue which is we we term somatic it
doesn't represent your whole body is one
piece of your body this is different
from the rest as opposed to the germline
tests such as the tests for disease
susceptibility and so in the realm of
cancer genetics there are now several
dozen drugs which are targeted to a
specific mutation and we have an ongoing
clinical program again it's nationwide
it's also in my broad domain called the
precision oncology program or pop and we
we basically take tumor tissue by
sequence a large number of genes reckon
round numbers 200 and these are
processed by different algorithms to
identify whether they might have a
mutation and it's a low percentage less
than 10% of all tumors that we test have
a hit where it it suggests that it has a
specific drug that would work but that's
important because if you you have one of
those tumors you want to know and these
drugs can be can be life literally life
chain it can they can turn the switch
off of cancer similarly for for one of
the cancers caused by Lynch syndrome we
now know that those are very susceptible
to some of the new immunomodulators so
we are we are using these methods in
common practice right now across the VA
in contrast many of the panels that have
been town
as in great of great immediate benefit
we regard as being a potential benefit
and so Ron already mentioned that we're
carrying on what I believe will be the
largest pharmacogenomic trial in in
depression ever youth because that's the
disease that is of specific interest to
the VA and we have hopes but we do not
yet know that it's actually going to
improve the the problem with the tests
that that show drug metabolism we can
show that the presence of a given
genetic variant might raise or lower the
potential serum level of a drug but that
doesn't mean you're gonna get better
faster and until we get to the point
where we can say this is going to
approve an outcome I don't think it's
really reasonable to use on a mass scale
we certainly do use all of these tests
in clinical situations which the care
can be individually difficult but not
across a clinic population Ron do you
want to weigh in sure I think I think
what's useful to also keep in mind is
this is an evolving area both looking at
the oncological perspective within
research development as well as just the
front pic genomic piece I think it's
worth noting that there was an a
gentleman in the 50s dr. Middleton that
discovered the connection between
smoking and lung cancer actually in
rabbits at that point and then I think
about two or three years later the
Surgeon General from NIH basically has
our Health Survey HHS has brought the
point across that smoking is hazardous
to your health
so VA again point number one but it's an
evolving area and if you take into
account the pharmacogenomic piece we
really don't know enough about how all
these pathways are in or working as well
think about it this way every individual
is truly unique
especially with the firm kitchen ohmic
pieces on top of that what is what is
the other overlying things that
modulates the metabolism could it be the
typical grapefruit juice and green gum
grapefruit juice
is it the issues of eating a lot of
leafy greens because now you're changing
your vitamin K and other aspects there
is there an augmentation because you
smoke all of these have effects on some
of the firm economic pathways as well
but I think what the prime study one key
thing that we're looking at is what does
the patient in the you know the
physician actually do when they get this
information
everybody here is about a lot of
different companies that will give you
genetic data and you can find out
wonderful things where you come from and
all this kind of stuff but the reality
is is there a utility to this do we
really know that once I find out that I
have this chance of getting well what is
the real incidents that could follow
with this and that's I think there the
question of the day people are
interested in finding out a little bit
more about themselves but other than
that is there really a piece I think I
just want to add one other point that
when you look at the pharmacogenomic
aspects for DHA or Veterans Health
Administration and piece of you use of
these these tests we Larry nye and
number of other individuals have
actually manuscript them should be
coming out in genetics and medicine
looking at our recommendations for VHA
healthcare and pharmacogenomics I would
like to once again thank dr. Meyer and
dr. Chris Godsey for their presentation
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through September
2018
they'll receive an email from fabrics
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay they share that
I'd also with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event that's
all for now thank you for joining us we
hope to see you again soon goodbye